hey cinephiles this is our list of the
top five films to see a 2014 South by
Southwest number five open windows
directed by nacho Vega Londo Elijah Wood
plays Nick a lucky fan who has won an
Internet contest to have dinner with
popular actress Jill Godard played by
sasha grey after Jill cancels the date
Nick is contacted by a mysterious man
with a tempting offer we're big fans of
the Galanos time crimes and hope this
high concept trailer will live up to its
promising premise number four before I
disappear written and directed by Sean
Christensen in 2013 Christensen won the
Oscar for Best live action short film
for curfew therein a man played by
Christiansen about to commit suicide
it's a call from his estranged sister to
babysit his niece for a few hours before
I disappear is a feature-length
exploration and expansion of the same
concept number three the dog directed by
Alison Berg and Francois Caron this is a
documentary portrait of the late John or
de vich who's attempted robbery of a
brooklyn bank to finance his mel lager
sex change was the real-life inspiration
for Dog Day Afternoon work fans of the
lunette film and look forward to
learning the rest of the story from
people who not only knew the man but
voytovitch himself number 2 Joe
directed by David Gordon Green last
year's prints Avalanche was the closest
we've come to a return to form for the
once india tour David Gordon Green Joe
is an ex-con who crosses paths with a 15
year old boy and is faced with the
choice of redemption or ruin if the plot
sounds an awful lot like last year's of
mud that will become all the more
familiar with the boy being played by
the ridiculously talented ty Sheridan
number one boyhood directed by Richard
Linklater Linklater is no stranger to
ambitious film projects shot over 12
consecutive years
boyhood Chronicles
Mason played by Ellar Coltrane from age
6 to 18 it looks to be a dramatized
equivalent to Michael Apted renowned up
series making it our most anticipated
film of 2014 South by Southwest